I'm Greg
I'm salamander Sally have you ever been
in a lawsuit Sally
yeah not me from one of my favorite
channels they do these great list videos
I'm sure I've shown you one before what
culture what culture ten movie scenes
that led to massive lawsuits grew by the
yeah I'm excited to check this out guys
subscribe to Sally's channel check her
out on Instagram where she dresses in
sexy Santa outfits not Santa girl Santa
Claus yeah hey hey I know at least two
gender-neutral people it wasn't a joke
I'm just saying you can just I know but
it's like if you just say it I'm
assuming you're being offensive it's
like if someone says it doesn't mean I'm
general neutral alien see we have lost
all ability to flow in position do it
what's happening I'm just just that
magical
[Laughter]
the high stress high cost value risk of
nature or filmmaking fees that there are
always going to the accidents on set and
that there are always going to be those
little pictures
cockroaches scuttling of the woodwork
looking for their piece hi
I mean who can forget the woman who sued
the producers of drive for quote unquote
miss marketing it as a fast and furious
type actually I support that woman
thanks a shitty trailer these can range
from the reasonable to the questionable
to the frivolous and ridiculous from
understandable requests for compensation
act of horrifying accidents to blent ly
outlandish attempts to fleece a
production for some fast cash
I'm Joshua cool calm and these are ten
movie scenes that led to massive losses
no pretend
rat-boy racists get out today Sarah it's
not terribly surprising that Sacha Baron
Cohen's outrageous satirical
mockumentary resulted in a number of
lawsuits with numerous court and court
participants alleging that they were
misled about the nature filming but the
legal case that took the cake stemmed
from the infamous sequence where Bart
hangs out with a trio of boozed up frat
boys who ended up making racist remarks
to of the University of South Carolina
students featured sued the producers
citing defamation that the film had
impacted their ability to secure jobs as
if they were fed alcohol while under the
belief that the footage would never be
shown in the US the two participants
were seeking to be cut out of the DVDs
release the suit was ultimately
dismissed in February 2000
ride her motorcycle across the
post-apocalyptic line still woman Olivia
Jackson received a life-threatening
injuries when her bike collided with a
camera crew in losing armor went to
early Jackson was left in a medically
induced coma weeks while the extent of
her injuries included air quat degloved
vests crushed facial bones severe neck
artery broken ribs tone fingers nerve
damage in her spinal cord and the event
to amputation oh my god Jackson
inevitably filed a suit against the
producers including director Paul WS
Anderson citing that the production
court elevated financial considerations
or the safety and quad this is number
nine injury by the producers how
extensively her medical coverage would
support her treatments oh no specify
damages and why the lawsuit is still
ongoing the extent of Jackson's
career-ending injuries makes it likely
the mammoth franchise which boss will be
making a substantial pay out the break
it's still going on Bryan Singer's 1998
psychological thriller pupil features a
sequence where 60 year-old bounciness
Bowden imagines he's showering
classmates as Jewish prisoners in the
gas chamber 16 similar claims one
complying with the request and the other
not all three boys claim the experience
traumatize them and file for damages
against the filmmakers on the grounds of
emotional distress negligence and
invasion of privacy here either horror
considerable press coverage though no
charges were pressed due to the
insufficient evidence and stinger ended
up with shooting the scene with adult
actors to ensure the film was completed
on schedule in the two-plus decades
since the fluid has released however
numerous additional unrelated suits have
been filed against singer citing sexual
abuse as of yet singer has never been
convicted of a crime
oh yeah
job Maclean's Black & Decker all lack
thereof die hard to you die hard alright
understanding a bit more lighthearted
god the producers of die hard to die
harder is an especially interesting kiss
because it stems not
from a scene in the movie but one that
was filmed yet ultimately cook from the
theatrical release when the sequels
budget skyrocketing to 70 million
dollars 2.5 times the originals modest
28 million bucks sought relief by
deferring to product placement striking
a deal with hardware tycoons black &
decker to include their new univille
drill in a scene but $20,000 on an
unrelated note if anyone for Black &
Decker is watching this and once again
Church that would be totally fine please
I have student loans to pay off
but you down the scene in question was
to see John McClane use the drill to
unscrew a duct at the airport while
Black & Decker mounted a die-hard
centric promotional campaign only to
learn three days before the film's
release of a scene hug be cut the
company sued Oh thousand dollars in
damages citing a court loss of
credibility despite never actually
paying the production of stated 20,000
still Fox eventually settled even exists
yet a scene in which junk Barbaro's Joey
masturbates using a pamphlet featuring
former model arena cryptic resulted in
legal action against the film so
director of iron man misappropriation of
likeness invasion of privacy suit
claiming that while she signed a release
on the picture a decade prior for which
she was paid well thousand five hundred
dollars she never agreed to the court
quasi pornographic content in which the
image was used hilariously the suit went
into needlessly specific detail about
the scene fixating on father Rose wet in
the misplaced interest of context the
judge threw the suit out and she
received diddly-squat for her act
I'm applied microwave definition drama
and mozo's there's a line there I guess
they're all more unexpected than this in
addition to receiving 10 Oscar
nominations David O Russell's American
hustle was slapped with a lawsuit due to
a scene in which Rosalind Rosenfeld
tells her husband Irving after she read
an article by Paul broader planning that
microwaves or as she calls them science
ovens remove the nutrition from food
brought to her a former science writer
for The New Yorker that's published
books on the apparent dangers of
microwave radiation yes sue the film's
production for misappropriating
Rosalyn's clamped to him because he
never once suggested that microwaves
reduce the nutrition bro do and more
likely invoke the Streisand effect by
drawing greater attention to a fleeting
and drop the average viewer wouldn't
even remember otherwise the suit was
ultimately dismissed with the court
deciding that audiences wouldn't take
Jennifer Lawrence's unreliable too
seriously
himself on the nutritional aspect of my
[Music]
[Laughter]
celly sued universal citing that they
use the likeness without permission
seeking not only half of the existing
profits from both current films but 50%
of all future proceeds as well media
some see the resemblance
azzam canny while others believe the
chera block design isn't inherently
original enough to warrant legal action
let me know what you think down the car
striking isn't it yeah
Jerry Heller's defaming and copyright
infringing depiction Straight Outta
Compton
it was only inevitable a lot of film as
incendiary as n depicts always
their share of legal interest from the
parties depicted here also down the
group's former manager Jerry Heller
Heller filed a 12 claim 110 million
dollar suit against the filmmakers not
only citing a defaming misrepresentation
of his character where that material had
been lifted from his autobiography
without permission
hello believed the film painted him as a
quarter sleazy manager who took
advantage the other defamation aspect of
the suit was largely tossed out in
mid-2016 even though Heller died of a
heart attack later that summer which his
lawyers claimed were provoked by the
stress of his depiction in the film hell
is the state continues a highway
infringement aspect of the suit late
last year though a judge dismissed it on
the grounds that hell is a stead failed
to establish his partial authorship of
the film's screenplay
number two Stu's tattoo The Hangover
Part 2 he hung up a part to you has
received several lawsuits over the past
50 years including an injured stuntman
settling out of court and Levine Vuitton
unsuccessfully suing for the inclusion
of a thick handbag in one scene but none
proved more bizarre and the sovereigns
has it there's a hilarious scene in the
final film West do you wax up with Mike
Tyson's distinctive tattoo plastered
across the sidewalk this prompting the
tattoo artist who originally created the
ink for Tyson s Victor Whitnall to sue
the production Whitnall claimed that the
design was copyrighted and that Warner
Brothers never sought permission to use
it while the studio waited back not a
tattoo as residing permanently on a
human face could not be subject to
conventional copyright law wit Mills
outlandish request to prevent the film's
release was rejected while Warner
Brothers made provisions to digitally
oldest use tattoo if the lawsuit ended
unfavorably for Beth in the end water
brothers settled with whitneyhl for an
undisclosed sum and as silly as the suit
might sound of pepper we've now had a
point considering how here our excuse
interface was featured in the movies
trailers and posters and that the
comedic context was in large part
offered by wit Mills design number one
2018 indie horror film ghost land was
hit with a lawsuit Foley on
axes while shooting the movies prologue
sequence 19 year old actress Taylor
Hickson who played a young version of
the character Veera hammer face
disfigured while filming a scene where
her character was banging on a glass
window after being instructed it she
fell through the window by using neither
safety glass nor doubles to further
worsen the film's already negative way
of a PR ruling in the production so
Johnson editor this and some of these
were shocking yeah so we're stupid and
then the other ones I was like I was
production that lenient and like not as
careful I've been sued force many
similar things on this list I don't take
precautions on any of my sketches it's
usually John John gets 95% of the
profits from the real rejects
I'm glad that led but number 10 with the
frat boys from Borat you guys uh you
guys deserved it being racist dumbasses
racist dumbass like you said those
things I wasn't it wasn't like an
article was published it wasn't like
Borat said it or people said it you're
the ones on camera who displayed this
behavior and said it and even if it
wasn't gonna be out in the States
even if your honor that presumption
there's still a chance that information
and somewhere in the were in a media
form in the world
to say that was dumb but from my
understanding a lot of people sued on
the Borat move this resident evil one
shocked the hell loving is but son like
the skin rips off so whether you say
like dig love face to see her face here
and if that and the fact that she did go
through that whatever reconstruction
surgery they had they did a wonderful
job because yeah they dig love that is I
mean not like their whole face comes up
I don't know the degree of it but that
just goes to show you man stuntman
really put their lives on the line there
they deserve some kind of award some
category because you're risking their
life for a movie
now she can't work again why did you say
just give her a glimpse on some and be
done with it like paramedic I don't
understand you would think that the
studio would want to sad at that point
how much money this frickin movie made
and then it says at the end that the
lawsuits still going on the studios or
producers or something they should offer
something up because she's sacrifice she
pretty much gave up her whole life now
for entertainment for what is a terrible
movie French is Black and Decker drill
one correct me because Black and Decker
didn't even give him the $20,000 they
said they lost credibility I honestly
don't know of anyone maybe went diehard
to came how people really paid attention
to product placement or something but if
I see a commercial for a product that
ties into some franchise movie to then
to some extent right I never watch the
movie and lookout for when that product
is going to appear I would never see a
Black & Decker commercial that ties in
die hard in some fashion it's not like
easy we're like yeah that boosted
seriously you're right about that what I
heard too it's like hey I want return
this drill because you were not in die
hard to has the whole reason I got it
cuz Bruce Willis was supposed to
use it at one point in the movie this is
an interesting one to me the one about
jon favreau pleasuring himself to the
photo of a model from years ago I know
how this stuff works because guys it too
you know yeah but I don't get paid for
it
they probably were just like hey we need
a model for this pamphlet pay for the
base pay fifteen hundred dollars it's
pretty common for movies like we just
need a model for this poster and fifteen
hundred like the usual base amount I
think they were saying where she got
paid fifteen hundred years ago and then
they used this photo much much later so
I don't think she was paid for the movie
yes I will say anything that has to do
with anything sexual you are supposed to
be aware of it before they use your
likeness so it sucks that she didn't get
anything after this lawsuit well I think
there's two different arguments to be
had here
one is the guy's mansplaining argument
and there is the woman's perspective on
this I'll play devil's advocate I'll be
the mansplaining if she is gonna pose
half-naked odds are there's gonna be a
lot of guys who who already touches
themselves to the photo of her so why
would she be upset about that if she
knows if she's gonna pose half-naked
that's what there's probably part of the
purpose of her doing it she wants guys
to touch themselves to her but imagine
the embarrassment of like millions of
people sitting down to watch this movie
watching a guy masturbate to it that
would make me feel so uncomfortable
because then I feel like people are just
gonna see me and be like oh that's the
chick that like you know I wouldn't want
to be known I wouldn't want my photo to
be known for in that with like millions
of people watching it Wow Sally you have
woke me up but I mean if she did like
sign off the rice and I guess that's no
end of us end it there end it there
you're right the microwave one Jennifer
Lawrence's character is like I mean they
were right like she's like kind of crazy
I don't even remember that like I don't
really who watches his long ass movie
cuz was she right about what they said
about the microwave a lot of people use
that argument like I've heard that
argument before no matter what name she
said I think people just say that no
one's gonna look up the author or
whoever she named dropped in it they're
gonna look up do microwaves the killers
mask jaws look they didn't even like
change the color of his eyes like I was
it the same thing except the tooth it's
pretty incredibly similar I can't make
the argument that it is not a distinct
look but I do think the amount he was
asking for was a little much 50% is this
kind of a shade someone inside but it's
also like if the mask was every frame of
that movie I mean yes then the mask is
associated with the film because it's
the killer it's not most of the screen
time part of the fun is not really even
the killer the fun is the time loop that
she's stuck in I don't think 50% is I
get if you're negotiating for like I'm
gonna go for 50s a little go to like
Fort nom I'm sorry you deserve something
perhaps but I don't but I will agree
that yeah he should have gotten paid
something sous tattoo is an interesting
ass argument actually to be had and most
people I think I don't know about know
him but most people will probably not
even go who was the artist of Mike
Tyson's tattoo because you see that
tattoo exactly so the association you
have is this do the Mike Tyson tattoo
clearly it's not a real tattoo it's just
a design that's supposed to like a fake
one that's supposed to make you think of
the Mike Tyson tattoo when you're
watching the movie I feel like the guy
had some ground actually to this it was
his original design that he put on Mike
Tyson's face Mike Tyson made the design
famous yeah you know what he probably
saw something for the design yeah
Mike Tyson drew the design himself and
just had some guy tatted on him that's a
different thing but because this guy
created that tattoo specifically for hmm
like I do agree that that's an artist
that deserves to be paid because yeah
they use it in all the promotional
photos you know and as someone who does
reactions I never have to worry about
lawsuits this last one you freak me out
is really that's shock it also upsets me
because I've been on big sets and you're
supposed to have fake glass if an
actor's anywhere near it like hitting it
or anything I say that you should go for
realism at all times yeah they should
have especially when you're dealing with
like what are the teenagers or something
like young actresses she's definitely
over eight under 18 I mean I'm all for
trying to enhance surrealism as much as
possible but if you're not a stunt
person and you're putting someone's life
at risk especially with glass that is
insanely dangerous you should always
have like candy glass or something I've
been on a super low budget set and even
they like a bunch of college kids and I
had to like bang on a window but even
they were like don't actually bang on
the window grab the great outside of the
window and shake like it's like even
like people that aren't that deep in an
industry you know like it's just you
there's no reason to take that risk
right goddammit the promotional photo
like what the hell that really ticked me
off that is one of the most insensitive
promotional photos that's so insensitive
very that's like capitalizing on your
controversy to see the most sinister to
create that photo she she deserves any
amount she's asking for but I'm glad she
won that is permanent damage done to
your face and as an actress that does
affect your career actor or actress that
really affects your career she probably
had like at least three more years left
in her you know jokes people and she's
still way better looking at me well guys
it's comment below if you've been in any
lawsuits tell us all about it go into
detail let us know if you need some
legal advice
trust me I'm your guy help Sally out of
many
lawsuits where she was definitely guilty
yeah as you can subscribe to the real
rejects click our notification bell make
sure to check out what cultures channel
as well Sally is a social media you
liked her trust me just go check her out
I'll be awesome I post some interesting
content when I do when I boom it's
interesting good man this is a man named
Scuba Steve scoop what are you doing and
you said it Scoob
are you doing like a Mexican accent like
a racist Mexican next School Bus well if
yeah well one person is bound to get
sued it's gonna be Scuba Steve yeah he
does graffiti art on public property all
the time and puts it up on YouTube he's
the one who's posting it it's a scuba
you got to be careful man
especially when I react to your videos
down the road I reveal the identity of
your location you really got to be
careful because someone's gonna find you
and hunt you down by my guidance but I
hope that when you're dealing with
lawyers and clearly when it is your
fault that you still stay pledged to our
patreon page you're gonna have to make
some losses in your income you're gonna
have to make some losses on do I really
need this Netflix subscription do I
really need this patreon is already
gonna stay but if you are gonna get
caught just let it be a graffiti of the
real rejects because that's like that my
way it's okay you did it Sally
you brought the shout out full circle I
appreciate you and you appreciate me I
am woke